maybe you've heard of a business process
modeling you sketch out some boxes and
then you get some arrows between them
that looks great
and that describes a particular area of
your business and how it works and then
a group of fancy business analysts look
at that
shift some boxes around
and then voila your business has been
optimized
well well kinda but process models first
of all are not made manually by
someone with a marker pen
they are produced by data mining
algorithms that analyze how a business
process actually works by looking at the
data and it turns out that if you really
understand
how a business works you can optimize it
in some pretty amazing ways so we're
going to define what business process
modeling is
how business process models are made
what they show and some benefits of this
whole exercise
now most enterprises have a pretty good
idea of the various business processes
powering their daily operations however
when they need to ensure that those
processes consistently drive optimal
outcomes a pretty good idea isn't really
gonna cut it
now business process modeling usually
involves creating a diagram or a
flowchart of the steps in the process
bit like that
with each step represented by a symbol
and process models are typically
rendered using one of two standardized
styles of graphical business process
notation there's b
p m
n that stands for business process
modeling notation and then there is u m
l and that stands for unified modeling
language
within these notation systems certain
visual elements have universally
recognized meanings when used in the
process model
so for example ovals
ovals represent the beginnings and the
end points of processes then we have
rectangles
rectangles represent specific activities
within a workflow
we have
diamonds and diamonds represent decision
points or gateways we have arrows
the arrows
represent sequence the sequence of the
flow
and then we have swim lanes
and swim lanes are used to identify who
owns which components of a process
so that's what it is but how do we make
them well a combination of event logs
and process mining
so firstly event
logs
these are digital footprints left behind
by every action that we take in an
information system and event logs can be
used to recreate a picture of how a
business process actually unfolded
including which tasks were completed by
which employees and in what order that
they did them in
and event logs can also reveal how often
specific events occur how long they take
and which other events are typically
completed before or after them
then there's process
mining
and process mining is the application of
a data mining algorithm to all of this
event log data and the algorithm
identifies trends in the data and uses
the results of the analysis to generate
a visual representation of the process
flow within the system the process model
so why build these models
a single process model can contain a
wealth of control workflow information
all sorts of data can be in here for
example we can capture
what is known as control flow
and control flow shows which activities
must be completed
in which order
then
there's also data
flow
and data flow shows how data moves
through the process and where it comes
from and where it goes to other things
we can look at
are performance metrics
and performance metrics are things like
cycle time processing time throughput we
can calculate those for various steps in
the process and we can identify things
like bottlenecks and inefficiencies and
then there is
resource
utilization
and that really is a metric
about things like cost per task or
number of tasks completed per hour that
sort of stuff that can be calculated and
used to optimize things like different
staffing levels
with all of this information captured
business processing modeling business
process modeling offers a number of
advantages and most importantly it
provides a quantitative data-driven view
of how work actually gets done within an
organization and this can be a
relevation that for many different
companies which rely on outdated or
subjective assumptions about how their
processes
work or how they think they work
now business process modeling also makes
it possible to do things like
simulate
change
so this is where we see well if we
change something what actually would
happen and we can model that in the
process before that's actually
implemented and find out the result by
changing variables in the model and
running the simulation enterprises can
predict the outcome of proposed process
changes and then make course corrections
as needed
and then finally business process
modeling creates a common
language
this is a common language that everybody
can participate in for discussing
process improvement initiatives
by visually representing a process in a
way that is both data driven and easy to
understand businesses can ensure that
everyone involved in a process
improvement project is on the same page
from the outset
process modeling forms a cornerstone of
any automation effort or business
process management initiative without
the comprehensive views of existing
processes and their underlying business
logic enterprises cannot effectively
optimize and automate workflows at scale
instead they'd be stuck
watching the best guesses of a
dupe of the marker pen
and if you want to see more videos like
this in the future please like and
subscribe thanks for watching